[Music]
I don't care the cabs started lining up
at the Greyhound bus stop in Plattsburgh
at around 2 30 PM as they do almost
daily according to drivers this is just
one wave of migrants to arrive by bus
some on tickets courtesy of New York
City the bus comes at three o'clock in
the afternoon
then it comes again at 6 6 30 in the
evening and that's what you do you sit
here until the bus comes the migrants
come here by bus and other means looking
for a lift to The Unofficial border
crossing at roxham Road a 30 minutes
Drive North of Plattsburgh all headed to
Canada for Asylum like Muhammad Sadiq
naimi about 20 years ago I left
Afghanistan I went to Pakistan turkey
and now I'm in Canada he and the 20 or
so Travelers are among the latest surge
of Asylum Seekers Crossing into Canada
via Roxanne Road according to the
Canadian government the number of people
seeking Refuge who crossed here jumped
to just over 39 000 in 2022 from about 4
000 the previous year it's probably the
Quebec politicians to demand that the
Kennedy government do something to stem
the flow of migrants saying the large
numbers is putting a strain on resources
in this province the truth is we cannot
open Boulder to 40
000 people 50 000 people the federal
government says it is in talks with the
us but on Wednesday Quebec Premier
France all legal urged prime minister
Justin Trudeau to discourage migrants
from coming to Canada
there could soon be some relief Quebec
immigration Minister Christine frechette
revealed that of their 125 migrants who
entered Canada via roxham Road Monday
102 were moved out of Province and that
most of the 380 who crossed over the
weekend
372 were also transferred outside Quebec
despite the logistical challenges here
those seeking Refuge like 90 may
continue to choose Canada in large
numbers because it is easy for Asylum
and also these countries support the
people also about their Asylum Seekers
yes all the more reasons The Advocates
to find ways to better support them
quickly
Phil Carpenter Global News roxham Road
New York